the big story everywhere is of course
the possible spread of the Ebola virus
now I know it's a dangerous disease but
I have to tell you I really think that
the Internet and the TV coverage of it
has been a little over the top and
insane which is crazy I agree completely
it's been totally over the top
we interrupt with a special edition of
CNN's instant reaction good evening it's
time for CNN's instant reaction I'm your
host Erica Morgan the big story out of
Burbank California
a man has sneeze the CDC isn't delaying
this time they've learned from their
mistakes and are already responding
[Applause]
and now let's go live to dr. Frederic
Miller of Mount Sinai Hospital in Los
Angeles dr. Miller here's what we know a
man has sneezed well Erica lots of
questions here with this one you know
how far to those projectiles go you know
it's a pretty scary situation as you can
see you didn't cover his mouth and it
looked like a pretty hard sneeze to me
okay I hate to interrupt but we do have
new information the man's name is Andrew
reichter he he's evidently a co-host of
a talk show on we believe QVC well
wherever he works the question is who is
mr. reichter been in contact with over
the past 48 hours for those questions
and more we go to an eyewitness who is
apparently in the vicinity
the man who hosts the QVC show mr.
Conrad Aubry um
hello mr. Obree um it's it's Conan
O'Brien on TBS okay thank you now mr.
orbino
in addition to yourself
how many people do you think have
recently come in contact with the
patient I don't even think Andy's sick I
mean some of us have allergies this time
of year yeah just to be clear by Andy
you mean mr. reichter yeah mr. reichter
yeah has Aunty been in contact with
anyone
Andy's really not here much he doesn't
even come to rehearsal so the only
person I've seen him with today was
Marta the cleaning lady are you worried
about being infected I no no no I'm not
worried at all I've shaken hands with
Gene Simmons so
and now let's hear some reactions from
people in the Burbank area when I saw
the big guy go out you and then the
people running back and forth from the
studio scary kind my daughter's the bus
goes right by that studio we're gonna
homeschool now I don't know who you're
talking about and that will give a [ __ ]
the show audience apparently caught the
sneeze on a cell phone here's the
footage very interesting to see from
that different angle and now I've been
told that Marta the cleaning lady is
being led off the premises we're gonna
go right now to CDC deputy director Karl
Lennox what's the latest Carl Erica
there's no need to worry
the CDC is about to neutralize the site
of the outbreak Warner Brothers stage 25
take a look Sarah I'm sorry but I
believe stage 25 is where a sitcom is
taped oh excuse me sir I'm just getting
another breaking story the cast of the
beloved CBS sitcom The Big Bang Theory
has been blown up
[Applause]
that is a real shame I love the one with
the bowl haircut those are some funny
nerds so very sorry
once again the cast of The Big Bang
Theory has been killed possibly by Ebola
we return you now to QVC and Vice
Admiral Chronos Abernathy
[Music]
you
you